it's the start of another working day
for rangers
in the mano national park armando zuniga
has decided to wear a cap today it's
damp
cool and cloudy here in the mountains of
peru
he lives in a village at the edge of the
park and used to be a farmer
but he's proud of what he and his fellow
rangers have achieved
over the past few years
[Music]
almost all the rangers in the park have
learned how to put out forest fires
we've been trained as firefighters
there was a fire here recently and i
helped to get it under control
it's important for us to be well trained
in fighting them
armando zuniga lives in patan marca with
his wife fanny
and their three children when still a
farmer he was unhappy about the national
park
because nobody was allowed to plant
crops there while locals faced a
shortage of arable land
but a lot has changed since then
farming used to provide a living for a
lot of people here
my wife and i grew corn
that was our main source of income corn
and potatoes
but since 2014 with the help of the
frankfurt zoological society
we in the village have learned to grow
new and different crops
have proved a great success they're not
new to the area
but people used to grow them just for
their own consumption
with the help from frankfurt their
cultivation has become more professional
and new markets have opened up
i'm so pleased about the money i'm
making with faisals
and the plants produce fruit very often
farming practices are not the only
things that have changed
weaving is a traditional craft here
practiced by women
it too has been modernized
they've set up a cooperative now use
electric sewing machines
and have developed a range of marketable
products
fanny cruz the wife of armando zuniga is
part of the group
[Music]
she says the women are happy to have
left their old lives behind them
i wouldn't want to go back to the fields
again
it's so tiring and it takes so much
effort to work the land
now i work and so sitting down this is
easier
we're happy we don't have any worries
well a few perhaps but not about money
textiles are a better source of income
than cruz takes her children to school
in the village every morning
the coveted 19 pandemic has left its
mark on these remote communities
and prompted major changes
the school is now able to use internet
thanks to pandemic relief measures
funded by germany's international
climate initiative
children spread out across the school
compound maintaining a distance from
each other and their teachers
many schools in peru have no internet
access
and until a few months ago the students
and teachers here
had to spend half an hour climbing a
steep hill to get any coverage
the school principal julia ojeda says it
was an ordeal for all concerned
ideas on rainy days the students
couldn't do any work
and when the sun was very bright they
couldn't read anything and the climb is
dangerous
one boy had a nasty fall and i once
slipped and dropped my phone and was
covered in bruises
another time i wanted to download
teaching materials from the web and it
started to rain
my laptop got wet and broke i had to
spend a fortune to have it repaired
the newly installed internet access is
set to change more than just schooling
has turned to beekeeping and he's now
hoping to expand his customer base
thanks to the project run by the
frankfurt zoological society
he's been able to find a new profession
while helping to protect the environment
farming is no longer an option for me
beekeeping is definitely more profitable
of course we have to take good care of
the bees so they can generate an income
for us
he appreciates that the unspoiled nature
of manu national park
is good for his bees and his livelihood
the people of patan marca are developing
new ways to make a living
while assuming responsibility for the
environment armando zuniga for one has
big plans
yeah my aim is not just to be a ranger
but also a leader in my community when
it comes to environmental protection
in my work in the park as well
i want to help to protect and preserve
nature here
and in preserving the park he's also
protecting the new livelihoods of people
in the surrounding villages